angèle bisaillon a filmé et photographié
de précieux moments passés avec son
premier enfant
on a des photos de lui des vidéos et
qu'on a pris à lui tant qu'il y avait
quelques heures de vie qui moi ça pas de
prix mais sept mois après la naissance
ces moments conserver sur son ordinateur
ont soudainement un prix fin mars les
pirates informatiques lui demandent une
rançon pour récupérer ses photos et ses
vidéos c'est de l'extorsion
voilà les victimes d'extorsions se
disait que c'était en crypté et qui
n'est nos filles en otage et qu'il
fallait payer de rançons pour récupérer
la clé pour décrypter nos fichiers
angèle est une victime d'un crime tour
en songeant ciel c'est un logiciel
malveillant qui effect l'ordinateur et
en bloquent l'accès en encodant les
fichiers ça se passe des fois sans qu'on
sache ça peut être un courriel qu'on a
reçues de quelqu'un qu'on connaît qui
nous a fait suivre un courriel sa ville
ses chaînes de lettres avec des images
de la musique des vidéos tout ça une
fois ce programme installé un message
flash sa fiche
on demande à angèle de payer une rançon
de 1500 $ sous forme de bitcoin une
monnaie virtuelle qui préservent
l'anonymat du fraudeur angèle bisaillon
à 96 heures pour payer sinon elle ne
recevra pas la clé qui décodera ces
fichiers il faut respecter le délai
sinon ça peut doubler tripler à
augmenter continuellement pied au bout
de quelques semaines ça il efface la clé
alors le monde henning la pression monte
monte monte
et malheureusement des gens cèdent à
cette pression là ils vont payer sans
aucune garantie qu'ils vont récupérer
leurs informations
après avoir consulté plusieurs
informaticiens anges elle décide de
payer les 1500 $ exigés et elle demande
à l'entreprise micro fixe d'effectuer la
transaction en vitrine le payer parce
qu'on est mis sur la carte de crédit
mais comment on va faire pour payer ça
le vrai problème c'est peau de payer la
rançon pour s'en sortir c'est le délai
qu'on ouvre le pays
une fois le store c'est toute sa
mécanique taux qui est compliqué à la
suite de ce paiement
angèle apprend que son ordinateur est
toujours bloquée cette fois ci à cause
d'un deuxième virus d'encodage ces
données restent codé la cjce qui avait
une deuxième agence ansa va demain à
pine vraiment une histoire d'or et
gendarmes ce que vous suggérez de payer
la rançon pour ne pas le choix de payer
la rançon si on n'a pas de bach aux
anges elle paie donc une deuxième rang
sont 2000 dollars soit 2 bits coin rares
sont les cas où les petits pourraient
leur être utile parce que les attaquants
sont quelque part dans le monde
et si l'argent vite coin ou autre est
transférée elle est souvent transférés
dans un pays où il n'y a pas d'entente
internationale
le phénomène est important le centre
antifraude du canada estime que partout
dans le monde
les cybercriminels ont recueilli 10
millions de dollars grâce à des cryptes
ou rançon j ciel les particuliers les
entreprises et les gouvernements sont
visés au québec la ville de dorval a été
infecté par le crypto world et tous les
courriels de ses employés ont été codé
les fraudeurs ont demandé une rançon de
1000 $ et la ville de dorval a payé son
porte-parole a refusé notre demande
d'entrevue
- je suggère toujours de ne jamais pays
on vous kidnapped le contenu de votre
ordinateur et on vous demande une rançon
un coup vous avez payé une fois et
aucunement garanti qu on va vous envoyer
la clé de déchiffrement si on paye est
ce qu'on est sûr d'avoir la bonne clé je
vous dirais qu'à 95% ça a fonctionné
c'est un mouvement qui ont payé
l'atelier par mimi la gendarmerie royale
du canada recommande de ne pas payer la
rançon
après avoir déboursé près de 3000 $
angèle bisaillon a réussi à récupérer
ces vidéos mais pas ces photos c'est sûr
que je serai contente les vidéos pour
les photos
oui très déçu déçu surtout que ça a
coûté très cher il ya quelqu'un quelque
part qui qui récolte cet argent-là
injuste si c'est le mot qui me vient
d'atteindre juste pour se protéger des
crypto rançon j ciel il faut éviter
d'ouvrir les pièces jointes de courriels
de sources inconnues et surtout faire
des copies de sauvegarde de ses données
angèle bisaillon a bien appris la leçon
on va poursuivre avec l'animateur de la
sphère bonsoir mathieu phénomène vaut
vraiment la peine qu'on s'y arrête un
peu donc ce qu'on vienne voir c'est un
des symptômes d'une vie d'amy qui est
vraiment mondiale c'est énorme
à titre indicatif de regardons une carte
carte interactive en temps réel c'est la
société kaspersky à 1100 ligne en fait
les attaques informatiques qui se
déroule actuellement dans le monde c'est
la pointe de l'iceberg
six policiers à la société symantec
céline rapport qui vient tout juste
d'être publié
entre 2013 et 2014 on arrive on a vu
vraiment une augmentation phénoménale du
cyber rancennes rançonnage écouter on
est passé de 8200 attaque à environ 350
2000 ces quarante cinq fois plus en un
an
en une année et le rapport de symantec
dit en fait la question n'est pas de
savoir si vous allez être attaqué cette
manière l'homme est bien quand vous
allez être attaqué cette manière alors
comment on fera comme pour être infecté
bon il ya plusieurs manières évidemment
le classique c'est de recevoir un
courriel qui est infecté on peut aussi
passer sur des sites malicieux et là
donc on nous envoie de l'information qui
permet d' infecté l'ordinateur
on pense aussi beaucoup par les réseaux
sociaux ça peut être par exemple le
courriel d'un ami qui est infecté qui
nous envoie du matériel malicieux et
c'est un courriel qui a toujours un peu
bizarre estime maintenant que notre ami
et francophones en soi un courriel en
anglais il ya des liens là dessus ne
cliquez jamais là-dessus
ce progrès peut être un logiciel de
cryptage rançonnage qui est caché là
dedans on a vu le cas de cette femme qui
a dû veiller là mais comment est-ce
qu'on se débarrasse de sa ce que ses
positions on peut passer par ces
compagnies là comme par exemple que
bitdefender qui offre des solutions sur
son site web il ya aussi kaspersky dont
on parlait qui offre aussi des solutions
mais faut que ce soit des virus très
ciblée quand on n'est pas dans ses six
ans virus dans ces virus le pour
lesquels il existe une défense d'aller
là ça peut être très difficile on l'a vu
le cas de la ville de dorval
il ya aussi récemment tous bering petite
ville au massachusetts que faire face à
ça ils ont fait venir des experts de
l'état fédéral de l'état du
massachusetts des compagnies
informatiques qu'ils ont ils en sont pas
venus à bout ils ont il a fallu qui paie
la rançon
alors donc on a des logiciels par
exemple comme crypto oil qui a généré
l'an dernier
environ un million de dollars de rançon
klepto là que lui c'est jusqu'à 27
millions de dollars qui aurait été comme
ça rançonner dans le monde sait pas
toujours des grosses sommes
mais quand on les additionne ça commence
à faire beaucoup c'est des centaines de
milliers de courriels qu'on envoie à
lens on a un pour cent 2 % de ce qu'ont
réussi à voir pour lesquels ont réussi à
avoir des rançons c'est énorme donc
c'est un jeu du chat et de la souris qui
comporte des centaines de millions
des centaines de millions de souris
selon la société kaspersky il y aurait
100 millions de logiciels malicieux qui
existerait entre l art à perte de riz
100 millions sur son site alors comme
disait axl rose dans le goudron this
will come to de django c'est vraiment la
loi de la jungle et terrifiant celle ci
où est cet aspect avec en faites
attention à votre ordinateur
merci beaucoup matière du plaisir et
pour poursuivre votre réflexion sur ce
sujet pour avoir notamment des conseils
afin d'éviter de tomber dans le piège
des pirates informatiques je vous invite
à consulter notre dossier web à
l'adresse que vous voyez à l'écran